bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
en allemagne au lendemain de leur
victoire électorale les
sociaux-démocrates s'apprête à faire
alliance avec les verts on s'interroge
sur la politique européenne rencontre
annoncée pour mercredi deux messieurs
schröder chirac et jospin paris vers et
les témoignages des reportages en
allemagne puis en direct l'analyse de
notre invité monsieur hubert védrine
ministre affaires étrangères jean marie
le pen devant la cour d'appel de
versailles le président du front
national doit aussi faire face à
quelques échecs électoraux décès de deux
personnes à l'hôpital edouard herriot à
lyon une panne d'électricité
exceptionnel dans cet hôpital est évoqué
une enquête administrative est ouverte
dans les pyrénées la présence des ours
est contestée faut-il ou non continuer
la réintroduction de cet animal enquête
dans haute garonne et dans l'ariège
gerhard schröder le vainqueur des
élections allemandes veut rompre avec
les seize années de gouvernement du
chancelier kohl et promet que son pays
deviendra plus moderne et plus juste la
victoire social-démocrate plus large qu
annoncée par les sondages et j'irai
depuis ce matin avec prudence la
composition du nouveau gouvernement
allemand prendra quelques jours
récit de ce lendemain électoral chez les
vainqueurs avec le reportage de notre
correspondant
olivier lerner prudence et discrétion au
siège des vainqueurs les sociaux
démocrates
officiellement les négociations
s'ouvriront vendredi
officieusement elles ont déjà commencé
le bâtiment qui abrite les verts est
fermé personne ne semble sous pression
en apparence il est décontracté mais son
emploi du temps est déjà surchargé
gerhard schröder a rencontré yoshka
fischer le leader des verts la nuit
dernière
l'allemagne va connaître son premier
gouvernement rouge vert de son histoire
première conférence de presse devant une
affluence record
humour et sourire lorsque gerhard
schröder tente de se rappeler ce qu'il
appelle lorsqu'il a compris qu'ils
allaient gagner un trou de mémoire
non ça revient
j'ai embrassé ma femme on passe ensuite
aux choses plus sérieuses avec une
question sur les relations
franco-allemandes sa conseillère
française brigitte sauzay tend l'oreille
cet axe est nécessaire si on veut faire
avancer l'europe mais il faut tenir
compte de la participation des
britanniques dans l'europe
les relations franco allemandes sont
irremplaçables mais en france comme en
allemagne
on pense qu'elles peuvent être
complétées dans le bon sens garrard
schrader joue désormais sur plusieurs
fronts à la fois avec les verts
totalement inexpérimenté mais très
exigeant on jugera vite de son autorité
distribuer des portefeuilles
ministériels à son partenaire sans
éclats de voix
ce sera déjà une belle performance alors
ce sera donc sur réserve des discussions
qui s'ouvriront vendredi olivier d
analyser entre les sociaux démocrates et
les verts une majorité absolue rouge
verte de 21 sièges qui gouvernera
l'allemagne les écologistes ont remporté
6 7% des suffrages que vous le voyez il
prétendre à des postes ministériels
le chef du groupe parlementaire des
verts monsieur jusqu'à fischer pourrait
ainsi mais rien n'est fait devenir
ministre des affaires étrangères c'est
un personnage très particulier dans le
paysage politique allemand reportage
philippe rochot pierre moscovitch claire
touchera clore le ciel face aux
questions de la presse auquel il ne veut
pas répondre
les 300 journalistes présents ici ont
déjà désigné ministre du gouvernement
schröder avant même que celui-ci ait
donné son feu vert
mais il y a pour lui au moins un point
d'accord entre les sociaux démocrates et
les verts
il faut réduire le chômage au plus vite
il faut une bonne dose d'accord pour
créer plus d'emplois dans ce cas car
c'est là dessus que la coalition rouge
verte sera jugée au mieux jusqu'à
fischer savourait hier l'aboutissement
d'un combat des 25 années qui le
conduira sans doute dans quelques jours
au poste de ministre des affaires
étrangères joschka fischer 50 ans a
voulu donner l'exemple pendant sa
campagne électorale en cours en son
premier marathon en 3h40
mais avec un mode horde l'écologie
d'abord les verts allemands veulent
ainsi faire passer de litres d'essence à
15 francs pour financer des projets
écologiques taxer les entreprises des
plus polluantes et instaurer un impôt
sur la fortune
le ska fischer a dû déjà réalisé ses
prétentions à la baisse
mais il tient la dragée haute aux
socialistes car sans eux pas de
gouvernement possible la volonté des
écologistes de donner la nationalité
allemande à quelques trois millions
d'enfants d'immigrés nés ici inquiète
une partie des allemands mais fisher se
veut rassurant
nous avons une forte minorité turque et
pour les deuxième et troisième
générations c'est un devoir que de leur
accorder la nationalité allemande
c'est leur droit enfin lyochka fischer
reste attaché à l'abandon total de
l'énergie nucléaire et du transport des
déchets un programme que les sociaux
démocrates seront obligés de freiner
quelque peu madame brigitte sauzay
bonsoir vous avez vous avez bien connu
monsieur helmut kohl et le président
mitterrand puisque vous serviez
d'intermédiaire pour la translation
qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui les
rapproche nous ressemble à monsieur
robert key laquelle elle quels sont les
points communs ou les pois divergent et
que tu es ce qui frappe quand on voit
cher à schoder en tout cas c'est que
c'est probablement le produit d'une
nouvelle allemagne c'est le produit
d'une époque qui a changé d'une page qui
s'est tournée et c'est une allemagne je
pense qu'ils seraient neumann qui sera
un petit peu plus proche de nous parce
que c'est une allemagne
les gens qui votent schröder en tout cas
et qui sont maintenant avec lui ceux qui
tracent la voie sont ceux qui sont le
plus proches du consensus sur lequel est
bâtie la société française c'était sorte
que de droite ou de gauche en france que
vous trouvez plus proche d'une allemagne
à la schröder que peut-être vénalité de
l'allemagne avant et pourtant on a
beaucoup dit que pour monsieur
mitterrand c'était essentiel l'europe
pour monsieur colle aussi est ce qu'il
ya une même volonté ce n'est pas
contradictoire dit ou alors est ce qu'il
y ait une même volonté chez monsieur
schneider on a on a un sentiment de flou
de sa part oui c'est ce qu'on dit depuis
le début de la campagne pourtant il a
multiplié les gestes pour convaincre de
sa bonne volonté et je crois de sa
conviction sa conviction et d'un petit
peu différente je crois de celle des
deux prédécesseurs dont vous parliez
tout à l'heure
parce qu' elle n'est pas basée sur la
même chose puisqu'elle ne relève pas de
la même époque
la conviction de l'allemagne que nous
avions jusqu'à présent c'était que
l'europe était nécessaire à la
que c'était un encadrement à l'allemagne
que sinon l'allemagne dérivés
aujourd'hui qu'il n'y a plus de murs que
nous avons l'euro il faut bien trouver
d'autre justification alors et celle là
elles sont évidentes si vous vous sentez
européen si vous avez envie que l'europe
vive et si vous vous rendez compte aussi
qu'on a besoin d'une identité européenne
dans cet océan de la globalisation qui
emporte sur ces flots les sociétés
européennes
tout ça c'est le cas tu cherches rada je
vous remercie madame de ce témoignage ce
sera tout un symbole c'est un communiste
allemand doyen d'âge de la nouvelle
assemblée qui prononcera le discours
d'ouverture les communistes rénover ont
consolidé leur position à l'issue de
cette élection notamment grâce aux votes
des électeurs de l'ex allemagne de l'est
au siège du pds le nouveau parti
communiste c'était la fête
reportage anne poursinoff christian est
un drôle de mélange hier à la fête du
pds
les drapeaux rouges brandis avec fierté
comme au temps de la rda
mais ce qui les agitent ont sérieusement
changé de look et de rythme
les communistes rénovateurs compte sur
des militants comme cette punk qui vient
d'être élu député pour faire oublier
leur encombrant ancêtres
le parti communiste de rda regardez tous
ces jeunes gens ici on a réussi à gagner
des voix l'ouest nous ne sommes plus le
parti du passé
les cadres du pds était tout sourire ce
matin en présentant leurs quatre élus
berlinois particulièrement fier de pétra
bas aux élus dans le centre de berlin
dans un quartier où vivent presque
autant d'anciens allemands de l'est et
de l'ouest et rabat au prouve que le pds
est imparti pour toute l'allemagne et
l'ukraine communes communistes nous
sommes les socialistes démocrates dans
cette république
ça veut dire qu'en 89 on a dit au revoir
au parti unique et au dogme communiste
de la dictature du prolétariat
on a réalisé que cette voie était une
impasse mais à part ce quartier très
particulier de prenzlauer berg le vote
pds reste très content au nez d'un seul
côté du mur qui séparait la ville en
deux et le parti compte une majorité de
militants de plus de 65 ans angela
marque bad la pomme député affirme
qu'elle peut s'accommoder de cette
composante âgées du pds n'est pas
question de changer d'alluré ou de style
il y avait une sorte d'unanimisme ce
matin dans les réactions politiques
européennes ou internationales de bill
clinton jusqu'à jacques chirac on s'est
déclaré réjoui est convaincu de pouvoir
continuer à bien travailler ensemble
tout en saluant l'oeuvre du battu le
chancelier helmut kohl se colle qui a
tenu une conférence de presse annonçant
des changements au sein de son parti
parti chrétien démocrate
et puis une même tonalité à pékin au
danemark en grande-bretagne à moscou à
madrid quant aux responsables politiques
français alain madelin philippe
douste-blazy ou bien françois hollande
il estime très important que le pilier
franco-allemand se renforce en fin
d'après midi le premier ministre n'a
juste pas eu un long entretien avec le
nouveau chancelier gerhard schröder et
donc il y aura une rencontre mercredi
trois sièges au sperme monsieur chirac
et monsieur schröder désormais à par
l'irlande et l'espagne les gouvernements
de l'union européenne sont tous tendance
rose c'est à dire social démocrate avec
trois leaders principaux tony blair
viennent-elles j'espère maintenant
gerhard schröder alors nous avons donc
voulu comparer trois intentions
politiques
s'agissant de l'europe de l'immigration
et du chômage a priori issus de la même
famille mais pas nécessairement mis en
oeuvre de la même manière commentaire
maryse burgot rose pâle c'est
aujourd'hui la couleur de l'europe
politique
la victoire des sociaux démocrates
allemands porte à 13 le nombre de pays
de l'ue
gouvernée à gauche ou au centre gauche
seule l'espagne et l'irlande sont
aujourd'hui dirigés par des
conservateurs
schroeder en allemagne blair en grande
bretagne jospin en france ces trois
grands leaders donne à l'europe
et malgré leurs différences une
coloration plus sociale en matière
d'emploi par exemple en allemagne
schroeder c'est donc une priorité le
chômage peu de mesures concrètes sinon
un pacte pour l'emploi
une sorte de table ronde entre patronat
et syndicats pour venir à bout ensemble
d'un taux de chômage à 11% pacte pour
l'emploi
un concept initié par lionel jospin
emplois-jeunes semaine de 35 heures en
france ces deux mesures symbolise la
politique de la gauche contre le chômage
à gauche la grande-bretagne l'est-elle
vraiment tony blair est plutôt
régulièrement qualifié de centristes
dans une angleterre très libéral il
s'apprête pourtant à faire adopter un
salaire minimum et un programme d' aides
à l'emploi des jeunes
autre grand dossier l'immigration en
allemagne
schroeder propose d'instaurer le droit
du sol pour faciliter l'intégration des
ressortissants étrangers nés sur le
territoire en france
cette volonté d'intégration est censé se
retrouver dans la loi chevènement mais
la régularisation d'une partie des sans
papiers est jugé par certains
insuffisante en grande bretagne l'heure
est aussi au durcissement des lois leur
prose et plutôt ferme en matière
d'immigration
reste le dossier de l'europe l'allemagne
de fraudeurs entend rester un des
piliers de la construction européenne
mais elle souhaite aussi pouvoir
défendre librement ses intérêts
notamment financiers la france espère
elle que cette frilosité n'entamera pas
le fameux couple bonne paris sur lequel
l'europe s'est construite un minage qui
devrait pourtant s'ouvrir dans l'avenir
à l'angleterre
même si connie blair se heurte aux
réticences de sa population souvent
eurosceptiques
voilà pour l'état des lignes et
messieurs hubert védrine bonsoir alors
tout le monde est content je disais mais
qu'est ce que ça va changer ou est ce
que ça va changer quelque chose c'est
pas à ce qu'il faut c'est que là ce qui
est positif est fondamental c'est à dire
cette relation franco-allemande moi je
préfère parler de moteur j'ai vu le
pilier largement par fred couples le
moteur mais ces salons de l'auto
faudrait non c'est parce que la relation
franco allemande a pour vertu principale
se sont acquis historique va entraîner
les autres dans une vision d'avenir de
l'europe et je crois que c'est ça
aujourd'hui la nécessité une première
avec cette nouvelle équipe à bonn après
s'être très belle et très nette victoire
et de gerhard schröder
mais vous dit vous savez qu'on dit
monsieur je choisirais plutôt anglo chic
et d'une région qui est un peu lié aux
la grande bretagne est ce que vous
craignez ou est-ce que compte fait vous
êtes plutôt content qu'il y ait une
sorte de trépied avec les anglais les
allemands les français maintenant pour
manier l'europe
je vois qu'il ya rien à craindre qu'il
ne faut pas mélanger les choses la
relation franco allemande depuis qu'elle
était heureux lancé refonder que la
solennité que l'on n'a pas oublié entre
le général de gaulle et le chancelier
adenauer a survécu et s'est renforcé
avec après quatre changements président
france 5 changements de chancelier et 14
changement de premier ministre en france
depuis ses lointaines années à chaque
fois elle a rebondi d'une façon nouvelle
adaptées elles sont quelques-uns à la
droite je vais avoir le pouvoir
oui l'expérience historique a montré que
en tout cas sur ce plan ce qui veut pas
dire qu'il peut y avoir des affinités
plus fortes en matière de programme
économique et social ce qu'est le cas
aujourd'hui et c'est très important
entre les gouvernements de bob bientôt
berlin et londres et paris ça c'est un
élément majeur extrêmement prometteur
pour la période qui vient
l'expérience a montré que ça
rebondissait et aujourd'hui on va le
voir sur les grands sujets qui sont
à présent je me suis dit que vous avez
créés sur les mondes de françois
mitterrand ne tarissait pas d'éloges sur
le mode colle sur le cac alors que là
monsieur schrader vous le connaissez pas
beaucoup oui mais c'est pas la même
chose
le d'abord helmut kohl on peut pas ne
pas dire on ne peut pas ne pas souligner
surtout aujourd'hui qu'il aura apporté
une contribution immense immense d'abord
à l'unité de son propre pays
notre relation franco-allemande et
d'autres pas à la construction de
l'europe
mais les allemands se sont déterminés
dans un vote démocratique une campagne
importante et je disais il ya un instant
c'est c'est un choix net
c'est un choix important c'est une belle
victoire pour monsieur choisirez pour le
spd
aujourd'hui nous avons à prolonger cette
oeuvre considérable de tous ceux qui ont
fait la région franco allemandes et
européennes depuis des années des années
et de l'appliquer concrètement aux
problèmes qui sont devant nous ensemble
parce que nous avons une tâche
importante à l'accomplir français
allemand et l'expérience a montré que
rien n'arrive à se substituer cette
relation franco-allemande même si ça ne
suffit pas même s'il peut avoir
également de bons rapports avec les
autres c'est ça notre tâche vous êtes le
ministre gouvernement socialiste veut
travailler avec un président qui n'est
pas de votre tendance là vous avez une
sorte d'hégémonie socialiste sur
l'europe qu'est ce que vous allez en
faire parce qu est ce que vous allez
nous dire on va faire de l'europe
sociale mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement comment vous allez
effectivement faire avancer différemment
leur je crois il faut pas avoir une
lecture partisane ou politiciennes de la
situation synergie je le disais en
matière de croissance d'emploi et c'est
très important que les trois
gouvernements clés en europe
color oriente le travail de l'union
européenne comme c était le cas quand
lionel jospin a obtenu de ses
partenaires pour la première fois avec
un conseil européen assume entièrement
consacré aux questions de l'emploi
ça c'est parce qu'il est très importante
en politique étrangère proprement dite
c'est moins visible parce que
naturellement
d'abord il ya beaucoup de situations de
deux coalitions ou de qu'habitation ou
autres et surtout parce que ce sont les
intérêts nationaux qui prime et qu'il
faut accorder pourtant donc c'est bien
ce qui se fait est ce qu'il sait ce qui
va continuer on peut pas appliquer une
lecture partisane par exemple au fait de
savoir comment on va trouver une
solution pour le financement de l'europe
comme on va adapter la politique
agricole commune qui est une de nos
tâches
ces prochains mois et ses treize pays
dirigé par des sociaux-démocrates et
nous on a un président qui n'est pas
associée à démocrate qui a une autre
tendance est ce que comment vous allez
faire vous entre les deux puisque vous
êtes un peu obligés de coller au
président la république aussi je crois
que naturellement il est des choses sont
claires des institutions sont là et
l'expérience a montré depuis juin 1997
que la france exprimé d'une même voix et
d'une voix forte en même temps y compris
dans les affaires européennes sur les
questions européennes nous avons des
positions et des positions françaises
par exemple nous disons que les
institutions européennes qui ont été
conçus pour six bons ils ont un peu de
mal aujourd'hui à la case c'est pas
possible de fonctionner bien dans cette
europe 1 à 20 ou 25
la france a proposé en forme de choses
pour que l'europe fonctionne mieux
demain dans l'intérêt de tout le monde
les membres actuels les membres futur
c'est un élément de la discussion
si une démarche française les
propositions françaises pour la réforme
du système monétaire international
aujourd'hui bien mise à mal ce sont des
propositions françaises
donc la question se pose même pas en
fait simplement il faut qu'on on
applique cet héritage cette volonté
franco-allemande et cette volonté
européenne aux problèmes d'aujourd'hui
juste une petite question monsieur
fisher comme ministre affaires
étrangères un verre ça vous fait peur
vous demander qu'est ce que c'est que
cette arrivée vous avez des inquiétudes
vous le prenez ça comme d'habitude à une
sorte de flame à la vitrine
d'abord c'est pas sûr deuxième rangée il
est le bienvenu si c'est lui et c'est le
je travaillerai mais c'est pas moi qui
vis déterminer la vitesse et les
allemands qui vont déterminer ses leurs
négociations pour la peut-être en saura
plus mercredi quand monsieur schrader
viendra à paris et rencontrera le
président la république et le premier
ministre et je suis prêt à travailler
dans un climat d'amitié franco-allemande
des mythiques constructive avec le
prochain ministre quel qu'il soit ici
c'est lui je le félicite par avance si
c'est un autre aussi voilà ça c'est de
la diplomatie merci beaucoup monsieur
védrine aux états unis à washington le
président de l'autorité palestinienne
yasser arafat et le premier ministre
israélien benjamin netanyahu se sont
réunis avec bill clinton
il s'agit de tenter de redonner
consistance un processus de paix
totalement paralysée depuis 18 mois il
faut sans doute pas s'attendre à
beaucoup de progrès 10 et on dans
l'entourage du président clinton à
washington pour france 2 le reportage de
philippe gassot et ariel mono
bill clinton avance au pas de charge il
s'agit aujourd'hui de reprendre le
dossier concernant la paix au proche
orient il l'annonçait il veut mettre la
sphère lewinsky derrière lui et
accomplir ce que le peuple américain
attend qu'il fasse son métier de
président
il montre ici qu'en dépit du scandale
l'amérique reste incontournable forte et
écoutez nous sommes d'accord pour dire
que nous avons fait des progrès dans le
processus de paix natanyahou et arafat à
washington c'est le résultat d'un
travail improvisée par madeleine
albright dans les coulisses de l'onu un
travail de persuasion d'autant plus ardu
et méritoire qu'aucune avancée
significative ne pointe à l'horizon
la crainte cependant d'une déclaration
unilatérale de yasser arafat à propos de
la création d'un état palestinien semble
différer la rencontre de la maison
blanche est probablement guidés par les
problèmes intérieurs américains mais la
volonté d'avancer et bien là pour rester
accroché en haut des sondages bill
clinton ne perd pas une occasion
aujourd'hui il s'agit du dossier qui a
souvent été occulté dans la presse
américaine parle affaire monica charles
enderlin bonsoir alors vu de vue de
jérusalem il n'y a rien de neuf
monsieur ross l'intermédiaire américain
et les rentrées bredouilles à quelques
jours aujourd'hui on a l'impression que
c'est seulement une poignée de main
entre vers en octobre est ce que c'est
ce sentiment que partage et se dire
qu'il ya vraiment rien de neuf
tout à fait il faut remarquer également
que la mise en blanche dans le bureau de
bill clinton il n'y a pas eu de poignée
de main entre yasser arafat et monsieur
netanyahou de ces discussions de new
york et de washington il ressort qu'un
nouveau et sow canevas l'effort
diplomatique américain madeleine
albright doit revenir dans la région
danis ross également le tout est de
savoir quand les américains jetteront
l'épongé
à ce moment là on parlera peut-être de
l'initiative egypte au european égypto
française pour la paix au proche orient
dans l'état actuel des choses le blocage
est total blocage total et urgences en
même temps changent en effet sur le
terrain la tension monte il ya eu des
incidents ces dernières 48 heures entre
des palestiniens de nationalité
israélienne et la police dans les
territoires palestiniens on s'attend à
un nouveau blocage demain à l'occasion
de la journée de kippour le grand pardon
merci charles est en effet très violents
affrontements pendant plusieurs heures
hier dans une localité arabe au nord est
de tel aviv après d'oum el fahem des
centaines de policiers ont tenté de
disperser des manifestants arabes
israéliens protestant contre une saisie
de terre la police aurait ouvert le feu
sur des élèves dans une école les arabes
israéliens voulaient empêcher la
transformation chambre tir pour l'armée
isrélienne de terrains leur appartenant
en france à versailles ouverture du
procès en appel du président du font
national monsieur le pen avait été
condamné au mois d'avril dernier à 2 ans
d'inégibilité et trois mois de prison
avec sursis pour violences et injures
il est accusé d'avoir agressé une
candidate socialiste en mai 97 le procès
se prolongera jusqu'à demain de nombreux
militants du front national était venu
supporter leur président
reportage valérie ermite guillaume
foutra à la barre jean marie le pen a
sorti le grand jeu
je suis une victime de guerre dit il mon
père a été tué par les allemands pendant
de longues minutes
il retrace son parcours je suis un
combattant un chef un discours qu'il
tiendra également sur une tribune face à
une foule convaincu et passionné sur les
frais jean marie le pen est moins
prolixe son agressivité le 30 mai 97
n'était qu'une réplique un harcèlement
dont il se dit victime
j'aime bien courir moi tu vendre
1 il réfute le fait d'avoir touché la
députée socialiste et dit juste lui
avoir parlé avec véhémence
enfin ils contestent la provenance des
blessures de l'élu et donne un peu le
vaste à montils que la preuve c'est
qu'elle déclare sa première déclaration
elle dit je ne peux pas dire que c'est
monsieur le pm qui m'a porté des coups
francs il n'y a aucun témoignage
il n'y a aucune image au crash de
télévision qui monte monsieur lebel
forte des coups à madame pulvar
mais cette affaire est orchestrée comme
elles le sont c'est bien souvent
regardons la vidéo mais c'est le fun dit
je n'ai pas touché ma place je n'ai pas
agresser madame sera simplement gérance
à quelque chose je suis arrivé j'étais
un tacle je suis sorti ses mains je
n'étais plus et quand on regarde la
grille on se rend compte qu'ils portent
bien la main sur moi à l'extérieur peu
nombreux élus de gauche puis militants
anti front national ont tenté de faire
entendre leur voix
difficile parce à l'organisation du
front national autobus sono et membre du
bureau politique
tout a été mis en place pour soutenir
jean marie le pen qui il est vrai joue
peut-être son avenir politique
et je vous rappelle les résultats des
élections législatives partielles d'hier
victoire de la socialiste d'être
casanova toulon sur la femme du maire de
toulon madame sandrine chevalier front
national à aubagne la victoire des
communistes d'alain belviso mais une
contestation par jean claude gaudin et
alain madelin de cette victoire il crie
à la fraude
et puis à dunkerque e défaite socialiste
seule candidate démocratie libérale
franck dhersin qui l'emportent
succédant ainsi au poste laissé vacant
pour cause de cumul par michel delebarre
il y avait des unions à gauche
explication marianne là c'est dominique
combes
ce scrutin clos pour le premier tour
s'était déroulée dans l'indifférence de
6 électeurs sur 10 laissant au candidat
socialiste andré delattre 60 petites
voix d'avancé sur son rival de droite
autant dire que tout était ouvert au
cassis et tous les quartiers
d'habitations sociales à 20 heures c'est
la surprise attendait la personne mais
ça je veux le dire aussi aux états
majors parisiens quand c'est renouveler
les cadres contre présente des jeunes
quand on fait l'union avec les anciens
comme se trouve ailleurs avec l'ancien
député manuel domergue a mis toute la
droite unie et bien on gagne on gagne on
arrive même à faire reculer le front
national à gauche c'est le malaise le
report à droite des voix du front
national il n'explique pas tout d'autant
qu'aucune consigne de vote n'avait été
donnée par le fn en cause plutôt le
mauvais report à gauche
ils étaient neuf candidats au premier
tour et nous nous avons bien sûr à
rassembler les troupes ça c'est toujours
une exigence de la gauche plurielle
c'est d'autant plus difficile quand la
gauche plurielle
on s'est tous les jours une gauche
plurielle une défaite au singulier de sa
mairie de coudekerque branche
andré delattre candidat malheureux et
controversé depuis le début estime
aujourd'hui avoir fait le maximum peut
pas joyeux que des voitures même de peu
quand on sait aussi que la victoire et
qui est à notre portée les élections de
97 c'est la première circonscription du
nord reprise par la droite le nouveau
député fera son entrée dans l'hémicycle
le 1er octobre quant aux élections
sénatoriales après le renouvellement
d'un tiers des sénateurs selon un mode
électoral qui a été qualifié par le
socialiste jean glavany d'inique il y à
une stabilité de la représentation avec
de légers gains pour le rpr le président
philippe seguin durpaire s'en est réjoui
les républicains indépendants les
socialistes est une perte pour les
centristes il reste maintenant à
procéder à l'élection du président du
sénat le premier ministre pourrait
demain évoqué une modification du mode
de scrutin pour l'élection les sénateurs
on a appris le décès du sénateur
communiste monsieur charles lieberman
celui ci qui fait un juif communiste
résistant un avocat passionné par les
droits de l'homme et qu'il participe à
l'élaboration du programme commun de la
gauche était âgé de 85 ans
à lyon à l'hôpital edouard herriot deux
patients qui se trouvaient en service de
réanimation moment où une panne
d'électricité a affecté l'ensemble de
l'hôpital sont morts quelques heures
après leur transfert dans d'autres
établissements
la panne d'électricité a duré plus de
deux heures une enquête administrative
devra déterminer s'il ya un lien entre
cette panne et le décès des patients
reportage à lyon peu de mots entre la
panne a duré près de deux heures trente
deux heures prendre pendant lesquelles
les 720 malade hospitalisé cette nuit là
ont été plongés dans le noir à l'origine
de la coupure une panne de secteur sur
le réseau edf
pour pallier ce type d'incident
l'hôpital dispose de deux alimentation
de secours
une autre ligne edf et ce groupe
électrogène les vendredis soirs le
basculement sur l'un ou l'autre n'a pu
se faire
la faute à une pièce défectueuse situé
dans cette cellule un hôpital est un
système qui comporte est un
établissement vivent encore de très
nombreuses installations techniques très
compliqué et sur les installations
techniques
on n'est jamais à l'abri d'une panne les
effets de cette panne ont été
particulièrement ressenti dans les
services de réanimation là où les
patients sont ventilés et perfusé à
l'aide de pousse seringue électrique
le plan rouge a été déclenché et 27
malades ont dû être transférés en
urgence vers d'autres hôpitaux des
transferts sans conséquences avait
affirmé dans un premier temps la
direction de l'hôpital avant de
reconnaître cet après midi le décès de
deux patients
malheureusement deux personnes sont
décédées sur leur site d'accueil bien
après le transport donc je dois ajouter
toutefois qu'après constatations
médicales le diagnostic était très
inquiétant
et concernant la direction de l'hôpital
a ouvert une enquête administrative
la pièce défectueuse à l'origine de la
panne est en cours d'expertisé selon le
journal le monde des procédures
judiciaires et des rapports d'inspection
internes à l'assistance publique des
hôpitaux de paris
révèlerait des pratiques frauduleuses de
gérants de tutelle ses gérants sont
chargés de gérer les biens des personnes
hospitalisées et il travaille
théoriquement sous le contrôle de juges
d'instance mais deux personnes ont été
mises en examen pour avoir détourné
trois millions et demi de francs au
détriment d'une personne hospitalisée à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris
explication olivier galzi pitié
salpêtrière ici comme dans sept autres
hôpitaux parisiens géré par l'assistance
publique des personnes âgées seules ou
handicapées mentales ont été spoliés en
cause les gérants de tutelle en charge
de ces personnes dans ce service de
responsable jusqu'en 96 disposer
librement de chéquiers livret a et
comptes bancaires des personnes
hospitalisées
l'adjointe aux tutelles habité même
l'appartement d'une des vieilles dames
hospitalisé un cinq-pièces rénové à
grands frais sept cent mille francs de
travaux payée par la propriétaire
toujours à son insu depuis les deux
responsables indélicats ont été mises en
examen et écrouées
comment ce genre de malversations at il
été rendue possible à l'hôpital de la
salpêtrière on refuse d'assumer toute la
responsabilité
il est difficile pour un directeur
d'hôpital
devoir se prononcer sur la gestion des
tutelles car comme vous le savez les
gestionnaires de tutelle dépendent des
juges ne tue pas les responsabilités
sont en fait multiples premier rang bien
sûr le gérant des tutelles tout repose
sur son honnêteté
mais en théorie il subit un double
contrôle celui du trésorier de
l'assistance publique et celui du juge
des tutelles qui doit vérifier chaque
année sa gestion or dans sept hôpitaux
de l'assistance publique
le double contrôle n'a pas fonctionné
retrait bancaire sur les comptes des
patients après leur mort disparition de
mobilier dépenses injustifiées
aujourd'hui deux procédures judiciaires
sont en cours un nouveau directeur
général pour la nes monsieur jacques
delpey ancien directeur général de
l'aisne des qui a été nommé par le
conseil d'administration de la mutuelle
nationale des étudiants de france le
parquet de paris aurait transmis à
l'administration fiscale un dossier
concernant les revenus personnels de
monsieur roland dumas transmission
effectué la demande des juges
eva joly et laurence vichnievsky en
marge de l'affairé elf qu'elle instruise
l'ouragan george après avoir épargné la
guadeloupe et puis déferlé sur haïti
saint domingue porto rico cet ouragan a
tué 300 personnes lors de son passage
sur et caraïbes et maintenant abordons
maintenant la nouvelle orléans après
avoir également provoqué des dégâts aux
mines en traits du mississippi des
centaines de personnes ont été évacuées
et on craint beaucoup la montée des eaux
des précautions ont été prises par
toutes les autorités américaines donc
pour protéger des habitants de la
nouvelle orléans
le ministère de l'environnement consulte
dans les pyrénées et tente d'obtenir une
réponse à cette question faut-il ou non
continuer la réintroduction d'ours dans
les pyrénées
tout a commencé en 96 depuis une des
ours été tuée par un chasseur et en
ariège une centaine de brebis égorgées
par les ours
nous vous proposons l'exemple en hauts
de garonne et en ariège de ce débat pro
ou anti ours
même si le petit dernier relâché en
avril 98 était bien mignon reportage
christophe la rocca olivier combe
ce sont les dernières images de l'ours
en avril dernier nérée l'un des oursons
de givat est capturée par une équipe de
scientifiques le temps de quelques
mesures et de l'installation d'un
collier émetteur n'irait repartir à un
peu gros dit sans se douter de la
tempête que provoque sa présence dans
les pyrénées
cette tempête gérard rolland est payé
pour en atténuer les effets depuis deux
ans il hébergeait itinérant chaque soir
il change d steve et de troupeaux ouais
j'étais inquiet à l'arrêt la basse il y
avait deux retours haut perchés sur les
comme six autres de ses collègues gérard
est payé par le ministère de
l'environnement et l'union européenne
son rôle repérer le signal émis par les
colliers émetteurs des ours et protégé
durant la nuit les trous pour les plus
proches
il est long d'ici à vol d'oiseau ça fait
ça fait quatre cinq jours être séparés
et dans la nuit aussi bien il peut venir
traversé la haie venir se servir dans le
trop pourquoi moi cette nuit faut que je
sois alors les berges et incohérent
dispose de flash et de fusées pour
éloigner les housses mais beaucoup
d'éleveurs refuse de leur confier leurs
troupeaux il rejette en bloc une
réintroduction pour laquelle ils n'ont
pas été consultés
roger audran lui n'était pas à 100%
contre l'ours grâce aux subventions il a
pu acheter deux chiens patous que cela
ne l'a pas empêché de perdre six bêtes
cet été aujourd'hui il est résigné
et qu'est ce que vous en pensez de
l'ours vous vous dites moi sommes
passagers c'est que je sais que je peux
rien faire long chaque année une
centaine de brebis sont tuées par l'ours
elles sont indemnisés deux fois leur
valeur encore faut-il les retrouver en
ariège 50% des estives ne sont pas
gardés
alors dans cette vallée les éleveurs ont
suivi les encouragements du ministère de
l'environnement
ils ont créé un emploi de berger confié
à john
un jeune de 25 ans pour ça ils ont reçu
une subvention de 25 mille francs
dégressif dès la deuxième année
une autre subvention a permis d'acheter
une scie be pour communiquer avec la
vallée mais les éleveurs trouve que
l'ours leur coûte encore beaucoup trop
cher c'est un coup de combien sur un
poste de berger jeunes et combien il
faut compter 1 au tour de senna
puisqu'avec les charges sociales et vous
avez combien de têtes sur 50 m l'aide
elle est actuellement de 15 me 33
je trouve que c'est quand même
inadmissible dans la mesure où je veux
dire c'est pas nous qui avons demandé à
ce que l'animal se relâcher quand je
vois les gens qui lasse d expérience
comme ça d' homo pour moi doivent
assumer pleinement les actifs on croit
en trois ans les subventions n'ont
suscité que trois emplois de berges et
dans les pyrénées on en espérait
plusieurs dizaines au départ du projet
les aides ont en revanche favorisé la
déclaration de nombreux bergers qui
jusqu'ici travaillait au noir pour moi
c'est essentiel je veux dire il ya dix
ans encore on travaillait tous au noir
ça venir quand on avait un accident
c'était la croix et la bannière pour
arriver à se faire rembourser
alors que maintenant depuis le plan
fonctionne depuis trois ans on a la
moitié des bergers qui sont
officiellement déclarés qu'on la
sécurité sociale qu'ont des fiches de
paye
pour moi c'est essentiel pour ce dossier
faire de l'écologie en france moins de 2
millions de francs sont dépensés chaque
année pour aider les éleveurs de trois
départements des êtres sans doute
insuffisante et dont le prolongement n'a
jamais été garanti il est évident que la
contrainte supplémentaire qui leur est
apportée est à la présence de l'ours
doit contribuer en face à des
financements pour les aider à mieux
garder ses troupeaux il y en a qui
existent déjà qui doivent être renforcés
pour leur permettre effectivement de
pouvoir assurer un pastoralistes digne
de ce nom dans les montagnes des
pyrénées
des mots qui sortent à d'autres mots
peint en blanc un peu partout en ariège
l'ours n'a développé mis le tourisme ni
l'économie locale et beaucoup se
demandent dès lors pourquoi l'avoir
amené ici cinéma mercredi prochain sur
les écrans sortie du film d'émir
kusturica ce cinéaste serbo-bosniaque
souvent primé à cannes venise ou berlin
propose cette fois-ci un film un peu fou
marquant son attachement personnel au
monde des gitans
reportage au brier de l'air christophe
airaud
il suffit qu'emir kusturica arrête sa
caravane pour qu'on se croit arrivé au
pays des rêves avec quelques lampions et
beaucoup d'imagination un village
assoupi des environs de belgrade devient
le cirque féerique de chat noir chat
blanc
c'est comme ça que je vois le monde
suspendu et flottant aussi riche que
l'imaginaire de kusturica
l'intrigué du film est impossible à
résumer disons que dans l'univers
tonitruant des gitans on suit des dieux
parents de jeunes mafieux des amoureux
et des marieuse les sourires sont
souvent aurifère les regards toujours
pénétrant
non
je suis de plus en plus convaincus que
non seulement mes films mais aussi ma
vie sont une version moderne du siège et
dans ce cirque
les animaux les gens font tout leur
possible pour que quand on arrive au
cinéma et que l'écran s'allume le public
soit hypnotisé la fable de kusturica est
d'une beauté saisissante
et tandis que l'on rit des combinés
cheveux les deux voleurs ont mal de
fortune on s'émeut de l'ingéniosité
foisonnante des plus jeunes soucieux
d'échapper à la loi du mariage arrangé
quand j'étais profondément déprimé je me
suis dit que le meilleur moyen de me
sortir de cette dépression était de
faire un film qui soit en même temps une
thérapie emir kusturica offre un fleuron
inattendue au cinéma burlesque chat noir
chat blanc est un condensé de bonheur
touchant et des quarts temps
chad marche à blanc d'émir que serait
cassé mercredi sur les écrans à la fin
de ce journal je vous rappelle deux
informations que nous avons développée
dans cette édition tout d'abord deux
morts suspectes à l'hôpital edouard
herriot à lyon il y aurait peut-être un
lien avec une fan des crédité de deux
heures pas détecté général dans cet
hôpital edouard-herriot une enquête
administrative est en cours
et puis en allemagne au lendemain la
victoire de gerhard schröder des
négociations pour l'entrée des verts au
gouvernement il annonce d'une rencontre
jacques chirac lionel jospin gerhard
schröder mercredi prochain à paris dans
quelques instants la météo de sophie
davant à 20h55 un très beau téléfilm les
oiseaux de passage avec charlotte de
turckheim et puis ensuite d'un monde à
l'autre l'émission de paul amar qui
parlera de vie publique et vie privée à
zéro et redit ce dernier journal
présenté par florence duprat en direct
du salon de l'automobile
quand il passera en compagnie de jean
panhard puis ensuite le cercle présenté
par philippe lefebvre 7h50 demain dans
les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra monsieur louis
schweitzer le pdg de renault et puis à
13h vous retrouvez carole gaessler et
rachid arhab à demain 20h bonsoir merci
oh
autre fait